[Music]
what's not an overstatement to say the
lefts attacks on America's border
security suddenly had become an attack
on America itself on Friday at a nice
facility in Aurora Colorado hundreds of
extremists stormed the grounds they
pulled down an American flag and tried
to burn it then they sent a Mexican flag
up the flagpole to replace it the
display was awful and it was deeply
revealing of their motives but what
happened on Saturday in Washington State
was even worse than that vilem
vanspronsen he was linked with the anti
fed domestic terror movement attacked a
nice facility in Tacoma he was carrying
an ar-15 and fire bombs he torched
several cars that apparently hoped to
burn the facility to the ground he was
shot dead before he could kill anyone
online members of an Tifa celebrated
their fallen comrade Facebook band Alex
Jones as you know because he's
hatemonger but Facebook is no problem
hosting and Tifa groups including the
seattle antifascist action branch of an
Tifa on facebook that group posted this
quote when our good friend and comrade
villain vanspronsen took a stand against
the fascist detention center in tacoma
he became a martyr who gave his life to
the struggle against fascism today we
stand strong in our support for yet
another martim martyr in the struggle
against fascism may his death serve as a
call to protest and direct action he
might as a lunatic who showed up with a
not with a semi-automatic rifle the kind
they want to ban by the way vanspronsen
may have failed but others should
imitate him in launching more terror
attacks on American soil that's what
they're saying
Facebook doesn't have a problem with
that of course well you think all of us
would spark some concern liberals might
tell us it's time for a national
conversation maybe gun control no and
Tifa has the implicit support of the
respectable left so far not a single
Democratic presidential candidate has
condemned Saturday's attack hard to
believe that's true we hope were wrong
maybe they condemn them during this show
but as of right now we believe again
hope or wrong that not a single Democrat
running for the nomination has condemned
a terror attack that took place on our
soil yesterday Saturday but why would
they condemn it they're on board with it
just a few weeks ago the New York Times
published an op-ed calling ice agents
complicit in quote mass atrocity and
then called for ice ages to have their
names and home addresses publicized so
why should we be surprised when people
trying to murder our ice agents Kim
Kelly who described herself as the
Labour columnist at Teen Vogue pause for
a second and just let the absurdity in
the labor columnist for Teen Vogue
that's how insane this moment as we're
living in any way the labor columnist
described vanspronsen terror attack as
quote righteous sabotage she compared
him to partisans fighting against the
Nazis and then called for more terror
attacks quote has vanspronsen and the
many other heroic comrades before him
have made clear there are many ways to
fight back against a violent fascist
regime perhaps it's time for more of us
to put our thinking caps on the decadent
rich really are unbelievable and Kim
Kelly is of course a member of the
decade which so is all of a antifa these
are the most privileged people in our
society of course this isn't the working
class rising up this is the ruling class
punching down when Kim Kelly by the way
isn't writing about the labor movement
for teenage girls she's also a
contributor at NPR you couldn't make
this up in other words government-funded
news outlets are directly spreading the
message of people who promote the murder
of government officials it's sick
this country's laws cannot survive when
powerful people endorse violence against
those who enforce the laws and a country
can't survive what is run people who
hate it